bon sixième match final et ce qui était
en train de faire un match de basket
la rencontre du joueur de basket lebron
james est le personnage du film the mask
c'est une exclusivité périscope ou
plutôt un pro scop un concept simple
imaginé par handy antoine membres de
déclic théâtre vous le donner un mot et
ont fait une impro et l'armée sur la
cession et où des quais avec périscope
le théâtre d'impro prend un sérieux coup
de jeune
pas besoin d'une grosse installation
deux téléphones portables un fond noir
et les suggestions des spectateurs
suffisent le réseau social permet de
filmer et de diffuser en direct avec son
smartphone afin de toucher un grand
nombre de spectateurs à travers le monde
entier
à la base on est en train de bosser sur
un projet de pièce de théâtre
et puis on s'est dit il faut qu'on fasse
un truc vite fait un rapide et puis on
est tombé sur périscope comme ça par
hasard vraiment par hasard parce qu'on
avait entendu un fait divers tout bête
là dessus tiens pourquoi on ferait pas
un petit show d'un provient ont fait un
essai on a fait un essai un peu entre
guillemets dans le vent et puis on s'est
rendu compte que ça a pris on a fait le
2e 3e 4e 5e 6e et là du coup comme
l'était antoine talents ont fait là la
8ème session là on a un peu habitué à la
scène du coup avec le retour des gens et
c'est ça nous ça nous est vachement nous
comment dire à nous à nous placer là
malheureusement
il ya personne qui nous regardent à part
un téléphone et des gens qui sont
derrière en train de nous mettre des
mules des mots de la bonne humeur sur un
média qui n'a pas encore d'utilisation
ou de fonctions vraiment défini ses
sketch improvisé une idée originale qui
a attiré jusqu'à 1650 spectateurs sur
périscope ce qui est hyper bizarre c'est
que on est sur du live et ce moment où
on termine l'impro et compte y aller
c'est le moment d'applaudir ya pas de
bruyne d'antan juste l'écart qui font
des ppp ppp eu alors une suggestion ou
une situation drôle a proposé à antoine
et andy les introscope c'est toutes les
semaines sur facebook et twitter